it's your boy KSI and yes I am on wired
wow I made it this is the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
don't Google this
what is KSI mean knowledge strength and
integrity that is uh my name I just
stole it from my halo Clan I used to
play Halo 3 a lot I loved Halo 3. I
loved it so much that I decided to join
a clan so my name used to just be on the
Xbox or legide BT my actual name is
olajideo latunji I also go by JJ because
it stands for Jedi Jr so I'm the junior
of my dad so my dad is called jede what
did KSI do before YouTube not a lot if
I'm being honest I tried to work for
McDonald's and they said I was
overqualified take that as you will
what does KSI
put in his water so I drink a lot of
water I tried to drink at least four
liters a day I recommend people to
always drink water stay hydrated adding
water to Prime Etc just you have to
drink a lot of liquids because I feel
like a lot of people are very dehydrated
and forget that how important water is
because you're what 80 plus water so if
you're not giving yourself water then
you're just gonna always have headaches
and there's a lot of things so drink
water yeah what was KSI childhood like
it was cool it was like they had rough
times my parents worked very very hard
had to probably have two jobs at times
just to get me into private school
wearing a lot of debt yeah I know my
parents are very loving and yeah we have
a very good relationship even better now
what is KSI boxing I guess some people
look at my technique and go that's not
boxing
basically I hit people and they go down
most of the time a lot of it is like
cardio cardio cardio cardio cardio is
King if your cardio is dead and you can
literally do anything I do a lot of like
treadmill running a lot of uh running
around the city the Versa climber a lot
I go on the bike we do weight training
here and there a Shadow Boxing yeah
there's a lot that I do but it's all
like at intense levels what is KSI
strength I guess
punching people
I guess that's that's one of my
strengths I love working hard I always
push myself more and more and more and
there's times where a lot of people
would give up and I'm the one still
going so yeah I guess that's one of my
strengths consistency people that's the
way to do it
all right anyway okay what does KSI use
to edit videos I don't edit videos
anymore it was a Sony Vegas I might have
got it legally
hahaha
back in the day
what was KSI first job YouTube that's
the first thing that paid me so yeah I
guess YouTube what was KSI ring walks on
the fight with me and Joella the ring
walk was uncontrollable featuring Big
Zoo the first fight with me and Logan
Paul was on point the second song with
me and Logan Paul was down like that
featuring Rick Ross little baby and SX
and then my recent fight against uh
Tampa a phase temper was easy it's a bit
of a banger might even have a feature on
it if you know what I mean you know I
mean
what did KSI get in his gcses five A's
Three B's and a C I'm actually pretty
proud of that way better than my a
levels what is KSI personality type I'm
a cheery guy uh pretty relaxed
introverted I love my own space so after
a certain amount of time I feel like I
need to recharge and just be on my ones
or a lot of times I just you know just
stay on my phone and just don't talk a
lot and that's just me just recharging
and just chilling what is KSI popping
challenge basically a song that I did
with Lil pump and smokepurpp and
we create a challenge where people were
able to do their own verse on the actual
song and I did a whole competition and I
had a winner Crypt won the competition
his verse is not his verse was fire all
right sweeped
where is KSI Lamborghini I've sold it I
made a song called Lamborghini it's on
100 plus million views basically I
managed to make enough money to buy a
Lamborghini shout out FIFA coins if you
know you know and I remember I was in
the studio with sway just showing this
chorus La Lamborghini
Lamborghini I know you see me in my
Lamborghini where is KSI album in the
charts so my first album to simulation
got number two on uh in the UK charts
and then my second album managed to get
number one so yeah I got a nice little
official charts plaque just chilling in
my house yeah I'm probably like proud of
that it's a it's a sick moment and you
know big up my fans for listening and
streaming Etc and I have very real fans
so if my music sucks they'll let me know
best believe especially on Reddit where
is KSI in wacky Wizards well even I
don't know this I think it's to do with
Roblox maybe I don't know oh right
how did KSI get famous believe it or not
through FIFA I used to play FIFA back in
the day that's where I started from on
YouTube I just post FIFA clips of me
doing skills and then I started talking
about FIFA started talking about how I
hate the game and how you need to
improve it that's kind of where
everything started from and then I
decided to just go wild and start
punching people and you know doing music
big
it's pretty mad how did KSI float it's a
really idea with rakaraka and uh they're
very talented uh talented twins from
Australia basically in that video we did
a whole skit and at the end I start
floating uh
floating in the air and uh basically I
just use wires that was just it that's
just why it's attached to me and then
they just got rid of it in post how did
KSI lose Bitcoin when it comes to crypto
I've taken a massive hell legit I've
just lost so much money I invested in
Luna but it was a coin that was destined
for greatness to the Moon it started
dipping so I was like oh let me put how
much I put in about two mil and it just
kept dipping it's still dipping my two
mil is now worth
think about
10p so
yeah fun times
yeah does KSI like Dragon Ball Z yes yes
yes yes Dragon Ball I love the whole
series Dragon Ball super I don't like
Dragon Ball GT I don't count that yeah
I'm a massive Dragon Ball fan I love it
well KSI join WWE no I have no business
to be in the WWE nope nope nope does KSI
have a jet no no but I mean with the
amount of money I'll be making would
probably maybe will KSI fight salt Pappy
hey you never know man you never know
what happens if it makes sense in the
future for me the fight's hope happy
then it will be done does KSI have a
bodyguard yes big boy Steve he just
rolls with me everywhere I go will KSI
laugh some people think my laugh is fake
a lot of times my life is just genuine
and I'm just a guy that lost a lot
because I don't take life too seriously
on this like gang it's KSI a minute yes
oh yes come on I've been doing YouTube
for like what 10 plus years and look at
all the things I have going on music
boxing Prime sidemen XIX like the list
goes on is KSI lactose intolerant yes I
am is KSI bilingual I wish that would be
so sick I know a few Spanish words hola
como estas
biblioteca queso yeah I think that would
get me quite far in Spain was KSI on
bake off yes and I was terrible I was
atrocious you get to see my red hair
honestly what they told me to bake isn't
what I made
was KSI on love Island I personally
wasn't on it but my music was I think
quite a few of my songs have been on
love Island I think not over yet has
been on love Island don't play featuring
uh Anne-Marie was on love Island Really
Love featuring Craig David was on love
Island oh my God patience featuring
Young Blood and Polo G anyway
that has been me on white
laughs